il y a une question à laquelle j'ai pas
de réponse c'est qu'est-ce qui fait que
tu arrêtes ta carrière dans la vidéo
[Musique]
x je sais pas comment raconter ça c'est
vieux maintenant salut dans cette vidéo
je reçois Emmanuel que vous connaissez
sous le nom de Clara Morgan longtemps je
me suis demandé pourquoi elle avait fait
cette carrière comment ça se fait
qu'elle avait arrêté cette carrière et
pourquoi les gens ne se souviennent que
de cette carrière c'est ce qu'on va
découvrir dans cette vidéo en rentrant
directement dans son cerveau première
question rentre dans le VI du sujet ça
plaisir est-ce qu'il y a encore des
personnes qui t'appellent Emmanuel ma
maman uniquement parce que euh ma sœur
mon mari c'est plutôt Emma ouais pas
Clara quand même mais ouais je navigue
entre Emma et Clara sans faire de
dédoublement de la personnalité parce
que je crois avoir tout
intégré en une seu lêtre mais euh oui
Emmanuel non c'est rare quand même je
crois que c'est quand ma mère est en
colère ah oui ouis quand on donne le
prénom le nom de famille la particule
ouais est-ce que toi tu peux me
présenter Emmanuel c'est qui elle aime
quoi je réfléchis pas comme ça parce que
clairement euh j'ai je crois avoir
trouvé un un véritable équilibre qui
s'articule c'est vrai hein autour de
l'amour mais c'est vrai que l'arrivée de
mon mari dans ma vie a tout équilibré
parce que il m'a porté il a soutenu mes
rêves il ne m'a jamais jugé et c'est
vrai que aujourd'hui on a choisi
d'habiter dans le Sud par exemple pour
que ma fille ait une enfance rêvée et je
navigue entre Paris et et le sud de la
France ce qui me donne un équilibre
incroyable donc Emmanuel Emma comme tu
veux est très présente et et je vis ma
meilleure vie en ociliant entre ces deux
personnages mais qui n'en font qu'un ce
prêteenom que tu as utilisé pour la
carrière professionnelle ce qui ce qui
existe d'ailleurs dans beaucoup dans
tous les arts on se cache souvent
derrière un pseudo en fait tu as
tellement maintenant fait ce que tu
voulais artistiquement qu'il y a plus
besoin peut-être de faire de nuances
entre qui et qui en fait juste toi tout
le temps oui je moi je je crois on
essaie d'être tout le temps je sais pas
si j'y suis arrivé en tout cas moi je
vis pas de de de désordre mental quand
je suis chez moi je rêve pas de Clara
Morgan enfin c'est juste que Emmanuel
Emma travaille tout le temps pour que
Clara puisse briller finalement et c'est
ce qui donne un équilibre à à emmaou
est-ce que tu as déjà pensé à te faire
apper publquement par ton vrai prénom de
de non jamais mais pas comme un masque
hein c'estouis je en fait je l'aurais vu
vraiment comme un échec ok c'est-à-dire
que quand on choisit euh de changer de
nom très jeune comme moi à 19 ans euh on
choisit une une carrière et en fait j'ai
vu des filles surtout dans dans le
domaine du du X puisque j'en viens
essayer de se racheter en fait en
changeant de nom non mais finalement je
suis bon ben dans mon cas ça aurait été
Emmanuel Munos pas du tout j'ai décidé
d'installer un personnage qui est une
partie de moi je ne suis pas pleinement
tout le
V et elle elle évolue donc pourquoi elle
changerait de nom h non il y a un début
un milieu il y aura une fin un jour mais
c'est un personnage qui évolue je ne
vais pas le faire mourir comme tout
humain ou partie d'humain en tout cas
Clara Morgan évolue elle est passée par
le X elle s'est émancipée et puis
aujourd'hui elle est sur scène il y a
toujours un rapport à l'érotisme dans ce
que fait Clara Morgan toujours toujours
parce que c'est aussi en moi mais moi je
je trouve ça fascinant et passionnant
d'avoir un un nom de scène parce que
c'est un regret moi de de travailler en
nom propre parce que je pensais pas
faire ça longtemps mais je trouve qu'il
y a un truc très pratique c'est que au
moins tu sais que quand tu parles de
Clara Morgan tu parles d'un projet
professionnel et tu es pas en train de
parler de ton ego tu vois ce que je veux
dire alors que moi quand je parle du
projet Fabien licard on sait pas si je
parle de moi encore et T questions que
tu te poses toi à toi seule personne se
les pose mais effectivement je me pose
moins la question peut-être que toi
parce qu'il y a eu ce nom qui est arrivé
ouis et en fait à la base j'ai pas du
tout réfléchi comme ça c'était pas une
réflexion poussée que je peux avoir
aujourd'hui avec tout ce vécu quand tu
as 19 ans et qu'on dit tu as le droit de
changer de nom c'est plutôt drôle c'est
plutôt de se dire ah génial je peux être
qui je veux je peux je peux porter
n'importe quel nom je peux me réinventer
je peux faire table race du passé
c'était plutôt ça se réinventer ouais
Emmanuel est un prénom qui a une
résonance particulière mais mais c'est
ça est-ce que ça p ou ouais tu tu l'as
tu l'as conscientisé ou ou à postéior tu
t'es dit ah même les personnes
s'adressent à moi avec le
prisme de de la charge de ce prénom via
le film et le livre complètement ok
c'est exactement ça j'avais pas
totalement conscience de tout c'est
c'est juste aujourd'hui encore une fois
avec le recul on m'a sexualisé ouis
depuis toute petite parce que même si ça
date des années 70 le film c'était très
présent parce qu'avant l'industrie
pour adulte tu es pas du tout développé
aujourd'hui ça passerait inaperçu au
milieu de plein de choses mais Emmanuel
est vraiment resté dans dans dans la
conscience collective comme quelque
chose d'érotique et une petite fille qui
s'appelle Emmanuel je sais que tout le
monde s'est demandé si mon père était
fan des films quoi il y avait ce truc là
un peu en plus avec la paternité de se
dire pourquoi ce choix et puis dans la
cour c'était Emmanuel 1 Emmanuel 2
Emmanuel 3 tu es laquelle je veux pas
dire que j'étais traumatisé du tout mais
en fait c'était normal pour moi d'être
sexualisé ouais depuis toujours et quand
il a s'agit de changer de nom je me suis
dit cool je vais me réapproprier ma
propre personne je ne vais plus être
dans le spectre d'Emmanuel et c'est ça
par contre c'était vraiment conscientisé
c'était la nouveauté du nom page blanche
par rapport à mon prénom déjà pas de
charge stéréotypée c'est ça qui était
déjà chargé ouais et pourquoi Clara
Morgan alors ça c'est vraiment il y a
pas d'explication vraiment à part Morgan
qui veut dire aimer dans l'ancien
français et par rapport j'aimais
beaucoup Renaud mais par rapport à
l'orientation que je prenais ça s
praêtait bien l'amour parce que
clairement je voulais parler d'amour
j'ai tourné avec mon petit ami de
l'époque je je ne pouvais pas j'étais
dans l'incapacité physique mentale tout
ce que tu veux de de d'être touché par
quelqu'un que je ne désirais pas et je
voulais parler d'amour déjà très très
jeune et quand j'ai eu mon outdoor en
ayant tourné un seul film bon je suis
mignonne on a les images je dis je
voudrais le faire avec beaucoup
d'émotions je parlais d'amour toute ma
vie je n'ai voulu que parler d'amour
c'était très important pour moi parce
que je pense que l'amour est la clé de
tout le respect l'équilibre homme-femme
le rapport le le l'équilibre de la
société parce que bah parler d'amour ça
semble idiot ça semble désuer ben en
fait je m'en ' fiche moi je veux parler
d'amour je veux parler de l'amour que je
vis au quotidien je veux parler d'amour
manquant dans notre monde et en fait
c'est mon sujet principal et je me suis
rendu compte qu'en faisant ce choix très
jeune à 19 ans et en l'évoquant on va
dire de façon explicite je pourrais
garder ce fil rouge toute ma vie parce
que j'ai écrit des livres sur l'amour
parce que je sorti de la lingerie parce
que j'ai sorti une marque de lingerie de
de de toys même en rapport avec l'amour
et la sexualité et ça me va hyper bien
et j'ai jamais voulu changer de de de
créneau par parce que finalement c'est
le sujet de mes chansons sur scène et
c'est le sujet de mon spectacle
aujourd'hui et c'est un sujet infini et
et une fois tuavais je t'avais entendu
parler de du besoin de liberté que tu
avais euh quand tu as commencé ta
carrière et je trouve que c'est un mot
qui est souvent mal compris moi j'ai
l'impression que tu as été plus libre
que les autres parce que tu as été libre
de mettre des limites je tourne avec mon
compagnon ou avec des femmes je décide
que il y a de l'amour dans ce que je
fais et je crois que tu témoignes de
beaucoup de liberté en disant je fais ça
et pas ça et c'est ça ma liberté c'est
pas tout faire n'importe comment quoi
non certainement pas la chose la plus
importante dans l'amour c'est la liberté
on ne peut pas aimer quelqu'un qui nous
contraint on ne peut pas vivre avec
cette TB d'amoclesès en se disant est-ce
que je vais être aimé si je fais ce
choix-là ouais est-ce que je suis dans
le cadre de son amour est-ce que je
mérite du coup est-ce que je mérite son
amour l'amour est conditionnel l'amour
n'est pas inconditionnel quand on tombe
amoureux de quelqu'un s'il change
radicalement est-ce qu'on l'aimera
toujours c'est des questions qu'on se
pose on a voulu dans notre amour parce
que voilà ça fait 20 ans qu'on est
ensemble bon pas 20 ça fait 15 ans
installer ce sentiment de liberté
c'est-à-dire que lui ne me jugerait pas
pour mes choix privés professionnel tout
ce qu'on veut et moi de la même façon je
ne vais pas le le juger je pense que
quand on parle d'amour en fait on parle
de liberté dans l'amour on peut pas nous
aujourd'hui se contraindre en tant que
femme je pense parce que parce qu'il y a
beaucoup d'amis autour de moi oui on dit
on est en 2023 les esprits ont changé
mais c'est-à-dire que tant quand on aime
si on aime quelqu'un qui nous contraint
et bien on aime on n'est pas vraiment
aimé donc l'amour est peut-être à sens
unique donc pour être une femme libre
aujourd'hui il faut déjà trouver pour
moi un amour ou être seul mais être seul
c'est pas facile quand je dis l'amour ça
peut être la famille ça peut être les
enfants ça peut être autre chose qu'un
mari il faut trouver cet équilibre de
liberté souvent quand on a fait des
vidéos ensemble on on sent quelque chose
que tu dois connaître dans ta vie de te
résumer à une activité qui a duré quoi 2
ans il y a 20 ans même pas un un je
crois 1 an et demi un an a 20 ans tu
vois mes chiffres sont pas bons mais tu
vois l'idé c'est pas grave j'ai j'ai
intégré ça ouis c'est ça moi je pense
que ça m'énerve plus que toi quand je le
vis m' alors merci du coup c'est petite
déclaration ça me touche ça les énerve
ça arrêtaé de m'énerver mais tu peux pas
vivre avec un énervement constant
oui je suis là grâce à mes débuts oui et
j'ai eu la force et l'énergie de tirer
le fil pour si tu veux me réaliser
pleinement en tant que femme et artiste
par rapport à cet épiphénomène ouais
dont on me parle et auquel on fait
référence mais ça me va super bien parce
que je serais pas là ouais je pourrais
pas me réaliser et si je je le vivais
mal déjà ma famille le vivrait mal j'ai
pas envie euh et en plus je serais pas
force de proposition aujourd'hui dans
mes spectacles parce que j'aurais envie
de qu'on qu'on m'estime qu'on prenne au
sérieuxose m'en fout de tout ça je veux
avoir le spectacle de mes rêves avec la
sexualité dont j'ai envie avec le le
pouvoir
érotique le plus puissant du monde avec
mes filles qui sont comme moi qui qui on
en fait pour moi la sexualité l'URA de
ça c'est une force ça arrêtait de
m'énerver parce que en fait je suis
libre de faire ce que je veux
aujourd'hui si on me disait non tu ne
peux pas parce que il y a eu ça alors
bon on ferme des portes il y a pas de
souci là-dessus mais je rentre par la
fenêtres et tant qu'il y a des fenêtres
benah ça m'énerve pas cette petite
partie que toi tu as vécu c'est un peu
Internet avant l'heure c'estàd qu'on dit
que avec internet aujourd'hui tu as dit
un truc il y a 7 ans qui a rien à voir
avec le sujet d'un débat et on te le
ressort oui mais il y a 7 ans tu as dit
ça et PE tu as beau dire oui mais j'ai
changé d'Avie depuis en fait non tu
l'avais mis en tout cas sur Facebook ou
Twitter et tuas tu as une activité
durant un an et on va surtout pas
regarder ailleurs on va le résumer je
trouvais ça heureusement j'ai des gens
qui regardent maintenant ce que je fais
aussi parce que sinon je pourrais pas
d'ailleurs assez rapidement du coup ta
carrière est elle est hyper intéressante
parce que tu as présenté après le jou tu
as présenté le journal Duard après donc
ça faisit un P de conneexion fait c'est
ça qui a fait ma notoriété parce qu'on
l'oublie mais pour moi c'est évident ça
a duré 7 ans c'était 2 millions et demi
de téléspectateurs par mois ouais et et
en réalité j'ai donné rendez-vous bah
beaucoup à des hommes soyons clair
durant ces ces 7 ans il paraît que les
c'était le rendez-vous en prison ils
avaient le droit de regarder un
truc le premier samedi du mois c'éit par
ah ouais ouais mais en fait évidemment
quand tu fais ce genre de truc tu
t'attends pas à la portée que ça peut
avoir c'était la décompression de de
plein de gens en disant c'est ça va je
suis quelqu'un de normal je peux
regarder ça à la téléouais euh le
journal du hardard ça a décomplexé plein
de gens et moi j'étais hyper Fiè d'avoir
parce que bon benah tout à coup on me
donnait quand même un rôle important
c'est que je regarder ce qui se passait
de haut ouais et ben en fait c'est là
que j'ai eu ma notoriété et je pense que
mes films ont on ont plus marché après
et pendant le Journal du Hard que
vraiment quand ils sont sortis ouais et
après tu as présenté 7 h autres émission
qui rien à voir je présenté dans la tête
du tueur sur disc Chanel si tu veux
c'était drôle mais en fait oui mais les
gens savent pas mais quand tu sais
présenter l'émission tu sais tout
présenter mais les gens vient te
contantonné j'ai eu de la chance parce
que on m'a proposé des projets qui qui
qui ont montré que j'avais pas qu'un
seul vocabulaire qu'un seul chant
lexical si tu veux ouis je je reviens un
tout petit peu à tes 17 ans tu vois un
reportage sur le capdag c'est ça je dis
pas de bêtis ça changé ma vie
apparemment du coup ça évoque quoi chez
toi tu te dis on y va qu'est-ce qui se
passe en fait j'étais en manque de
liberté parce que mes parents même s'ils
étaient plein plein de bonnes intentions
n'ont pas agi comme je l'aurais souhaité
et en même temps je pense que je leur
dois toute ma carrière à cause de ça ça
crée un un un électrochoc chez moi
d'urgence de liberté en fait j'ai
analysé que ma mère à un certain
stade n'était plus protectrice pour moi
h mais pour me garder ok quand ça je
l'ai intégré j'ai voulu me venger je
suis devenue violente ouais je dis
violente parce que oui il y avait
beaucoup de violence en moi je partie de
ces de ces adolescents incontrôlables
qui envoient des chaises à travers la
pièce parce que la liber le manque de
liberté peut créer ça ouais pas
texploser les murs au sensur quoi là
cette rage que j'ai garder toute ma vie
que j'ai encore ça a été le moteur pour
dire ok mais en fait ma vie elle
m'appartient et et et et croyez-moi elle
va vraiment m'appartenir parce que je
vous aime mais si vous m'aimez vous
devez absolument me laisser contrôler ma
vie et je suis rentrée en guerre j'ai eu
mal de faire mal à ma mère quand j'ai
choisi ce choix du X j'ai eu mal parce
que je suis d'origine espagnole parce
que mon grand-père m'a élevé et quand le
voisin lui a dit parce qu'on a jamais
osé ma mère non' plus bah elle s'est
pris une une grande gifle ouais dans la
tête en disant que bah c'est c'est ta
faute c'est son père qui frpp mal éduqué
pour moi ça tout ça je l'ai mal vécu
mais en réalité je vivais mal pour eux
et moi j'étais hyper bien h j'étais
hyper bien parce que je me disais bah
oui mais c'est dommage qu'il le vivent
comme ça parce qu'ils ne savent pas ce
que je vais devenir et j'étais comme ça
et en même temps du coup par rapport à
leur à leur souffrance je me devais de
réussir oui c'est vrai je comprends a et
donc ce cap d'Agde ça a été pour moi la
porte ok la porte parce que je suis dit
c'est marrant il y a des gens tout nu
mais j'ai 17 ans mais quelle éducation
j'ai eu par rapport à mais en fait le
monde est vaste pas tout le monde pense
comme ma famille pour ceux qui nous
écoutent et qui savent pas on parle on
parle de naturisme ah oui oui
complètement à la base he c'était
vraiment la liberté de se balader nu
alors évidemment ce n pas une liberté en
soi mais j'ai vu là une façon différente
de vivre par rapport à tout ce que je
connaissais et je voulais euh je voulais
casser le mur quoi je voulais casser le
mur que ma mère ma famille avait
dressé autour de moi je l'ai pét au sens
littéral parce que tu t'es dépouillé de
tes vêtements donc c'est très littéral
je l'ai cassé comme ça ce mur et à
partir de là j'ai rencontré des gens
j'ai rencontré des gens qui allaient au
salon de l'érotisme à Paris j'ai
rencontré des gens qui menaient une vie
merveilleuse enfin selon mes mes yeux
d'enfants parce que 19 ans les est
encore j'ai vu des gens l'âge de mes
grands-parents se tenir en laiss ok
c'està-dire que c'était Walt Disney pour
les grands je dis mais qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce monde qu'on m'a caché en
fait j'avais juste envie de leur parler
de leur Demer pourquoi ils s changé
pourquoi ils avaient besoin de ça dans
leur vie comment ils en étaient venus au
Natur alors j'étais en mode journalist
ouais c'est très bizarre parce que moi
je me suis jamais échangé j'ai jamais
moi mon mec je voulais pas qu'il aille
ailleurs j'avais pas du tout la la
maturité pourquoi que ce soit de ce
genre là j'avais 19 ans j'aimis mon mec
je voulais pas qu'il regarde d'autrre
filles enfin on était j'étais pas du
tout dans le truc d'échanger he c'était
une expérience sociale de pourquoi vous
faites ça en interview H24 mais alors
lui mais pourquoi il souffre pas parce
que pour moi la la jalousie était un
problème à cette époque aujourd'hui je
m'en suis complètement défaite parce que
ça ne sert à rien je m'en rends compte
mais quand on a 19 ans on le sait pas on
est jalou et on peut pas faire autrement
donc mes questions étaient sur la
jalousie sur mais pourquoi bah c'était
que des coupes de 35 40 ans moi j'avais
19 ans donc ça a été la porte ouverte en
fait sur le monde et j'ai eu envie de de
rejoindre ses copains que je m'étais
fait au salon de PR temps de te répondre
il prenait le temps de t'expliquer ahi
ouais et ils m'ont tous dit ben tu viens
pas au salon à Paris et j'ai dit à Greg
on petit ami de l'époque et il m'a fait
la surprise pour mon anniversaire pour
mes 20 ans ok on s on a débarqué à Paris
comme ça par connaissance de de de
naturistes échangistes qu'on avait
rencontré au CDAG ouais c'est comme ça
que ça a commencé et c'est ce qui fera
après le pont vers l'envie de faire de
de d'essayer du X bah c'est-à-dire que
quand on s'est pointé là-bas on avait 19
ans on était beau faut dire la vérité on
était libéré enfin on avait envie de se
libérer euh et et et il ils nous ont
sauté dessus au sens
propre Marc dorsell voulait nous signer
bah eux pour eux ils ont vu un petit
couple venir d'eux même parce qu'après
je me suis rendu compte que c'est
c'était pas si facile de caster quoi
alors on m'a proposé en premier
d'intégrer un petit théâtre qui est dans
le salon de l'errotis pour faire un
strip teas ok alors j'étais un peu bon
j'étais quand même je venais de mon
enfin j'étais encore en BTS Action co ok
donc si tu veux bah oui pour Mo pour moi
c'était la semaine de vacances je crois
que j'ai grillé l'école pour venir ok
avec avec des paillettes le côté Glo qui
a jamais été dans dans mon univers si tu
veux et donc je fais mes premiers
striptis sur ce salon et Greg en fait a
été embauché euh au au snack euh du du
salon pour vendre des sandwichs
incroyable ouais ouais ben parce que si
tu veux on était facile d'accès on était
marrant parce que oui mais dans ce
secteur il y a souvent des gens plus
âgés qui traînent un peu enfin tu vois
il y a un peu envie d'expérimenter ah
ben nous on était frais tu vois donc
tout de suite donc on s'est fait un
petit billet sur le salon Mar elle est
venue me voir mes feuillets Fred de
copul à tout le monde et j'étais en mode
non non mais attendez nous c'est une
blague on est là pour le weekend et tout
ça Fred a eu les bons mots et ça a été
la rencontre une des rencontres clés de
ma vie où il m'a dit tu as pas compris
on vous aime tellement vous êtes
tellement bien on vous veut en couple je
dis non mais moi tu as pas compris je
peux pas être actrice ça existe pas de
il me dit si si on va l'inventer j'ai
comment ça l'inventer une actrice X
obligé de tourner avec plein de mecs
elle arrive sur tu sais elles arrivent
sur le plateau elles savent pas avec qui
vont tourner enfin c un concept
totalement oui mais si c'est un concept
totalement impossible à mux ouais dit
non non mais on va inventer ça pour toi
je bon écoute je vais retourner en
classe et puis on verra et j'avoue que
quand je suis retourné dans ma classe de
BTS Action co bah le monde tournait
autour de moi sans moi quoi j'étais
ailleurs euh j'ai voulu parler à une
amie que j'avais à côté de moi pour lui
dire que j'avais découvert que j'étais
bisexuelle depuis toujours mais que
c'est là-bas dans ce contexte du capdac
depuis de Paris j'avais j'avais pas eu
d'expérience mais je m'étais rendu
compte en fait de ton propre désir ou
voilà et en fait elle a très très mal
réagi elle voulait plus me parler elle
pensait que je la dragué alors que alors
vraiment j'étais à des bornes de çache
il voulais juste me confier et si tu
veux ça plus le fait d'avoir la lumière
parisienne quelqu'un qui me propose de
monter un concept totalement sur mes
propres envies j'ai eu confiance en lui
il a eu les bons mots et tout a démarré
parce que dans cette classe ben j'étais
plus à ma place ouais il y a une
question à laquelle j'ai pas de réponse
c'est qu'est-ce qui fait que tu arrêtes
ta carrière dans la vidéo x j'en ai peu
parlé ah donc c'est ça ouais parce que
je suis plutôt attentif mais euh tu me
touches tellement par ton intérêt euh je
vais te raconter un petit peu
euh je sais pas comment raconter ça
c'est vieux maintenant
euh Greg avait pas mal de problèmes
euh h le premier amour tu sais celui
qu'on rencontre à 16 ans et euh il avait
un problème psychotique j'ai cherché à
l'aider et euh je n'ai pas réussi
ok très clair à peu près clair ouais et
h c'est un problème que je connaissais
pas mal parce que mon papa avait
beaucoup fréquenter les les hôpitaux
psychiatriques et ma maman en fait je le
dis parce que j'ai jamais trop
l'occasion et je pense que c'est
important que les les gens entendent ça
ma mère me disait quand mon père a eu
ses
problèmes
si s'il était malade du cœur s'il était
malade d'un cancer d'autre chose
euh je le lâcherai pas donc là c'est une
maladie mentale
et c'est pareil je la traiterit de la
même façon et comme quoi la vie est est
incroyable j'ai vécu la même chose que
ma mère mère sur mon premier amour je
pense que je devais le vivre pour
comprendre ma mère en fait quelque chose
comme ça je pense l'univers nous envoie
des défis en fonction de ce qu'on est
capable de donner et ce qu'on doit vivre
surt et je devais le vivre et j'ai
souvent dit que Greg voulait continuer
sa carrière
euh de X alors que moi non parce que
j'en avais fait le tour ce qui est vrai
je laissé s'enfuir comme ça parce que je
ne pouvais plus gérer
et il est mort à 34 ans parce
que personne pouvait le
sauver c'est quelqu'un qui voulait
brûler le la corde de la vie parler
debouts
et moi je je je n'avais qu'un seul côté
celui de la vie que je voulais brûler
aussi
mais j'avais toujours une conscience
de mes limites pas lui et moi j'étais
allée jusqu'à mes limites pour essayer
de de sauver ça de le sauver lui de
sauver notre amour et je me suis très
assez rapidement rendue compte que que
je ne pourrais pas parce que on peut pas
non plus sauver quelqu'un qui n'a pas
envie de l'être oui on risque de te
détruire toi-même quoi voilà et c'est un
petit peu comme ça que que ça s'est
terminé ça j'avais un an dans le X on
avait tourné quatre filmes
j'ai tourné avec un film avec y Scott un
autre acteur parce que si tu veux
c'était comme un adieu en fait je
voulais me
vengerque je l'ai jamais dit mais je
voulais un peu me venger à l'époque
parce que lui avait tourné avec d'autres
filles et c'était pour
moi bon j'étis attirée par Yan Scott
sinon je l'aurais jamais fait et je me
suis dit c'est une façon de terminer de
de prouver que si lui peut le faire avec
d'autres filles moi aussi et ça a été ma
dernière scène et je pense c'est mon 5e
film et ce qui est marrant c'est qu'on
s'est pas parlé pendant des années et
euh quand j'ai sorti mon dis que j'étais
déjà avec mon mari actuel il m'a appelé
euh ça a été un appel de réconciliation
parce qu'il me disait bon ben tu as bien
fait regarde tu tu t'es trouvé en
musique tout ça et cetera euh si un jour
je me réveille avec du talent je
t'appellerai pour qu'on fasse un titre
ensemble bon bref et et il est mort de
jours après ok c'était étonnant parce
que ça faisait des années qu'on s'était
pas parlé et il m'a appelé pour me dire
au revoir tu vois je l'ai pris comme ça
finalement je ne suis pas triste même si
j'en pleure un peu parce que je pense
qu'il a eu la vie qu'il voulait il a une
vie extrêmement rock and roll je pense
que c'était son destin avec le temps et
que on devait vivre ce petit bout de
destin ensemble c'est d'autant plus fort
et plus sage de ta part de pas juger en
fait sa manière de ne pas vouloir être
sauvé ah non non mais il avait une
maladie mentale qui qui qui est
terrassante qui est la schizophrénie qui
qui l' pris à la suite d'une d'une prise
de drogue trop importante OK et lui il a
vriillé en fait et donc il y a des
moments d'acalmie tu sais dans la
schizophrénie des moments où ça va bien
et des moments où tu dis mais moi je
peux pas retenir ça c'est c'est trop
fort c'est trop gros il a besoin de plus
de soutien et si tu veux il a pu avoir
quelques années sans mois de folie entre
X et folie enfin on dit folie mais je
pense que c'est des gens illuminés qui
voient d'autres choses que nous on ne
voit pas qui ont ouvert une porte voilà
donc je suis pas triste pour lui je
pense qu'il a eu quand même une très
belle vie euh mais moi je pouvais je la
voulais plus plus longue et je voulais
créer une famille je
voulais quelque chose d'un peu plus
normal peut-être et et voilà à un moment
et leï j'en avait fait le tour et de
notre couple aussi et et de de l'espoir
de pouvoir le sauverou tout un chapitre
qui ser ouai complètement donc encore
l'univers qui qui qui qui te fait
tourner la page de façon naturelle
finalement bah c'est très généreux merci
qu'est-ce que tu dirais aujourd'hui si
une jeune femme et ça t'est peut-être
déjà arrivé vient te te demander conseil
à toi pour euh pour le fait de commencer
le X ou avec une envie de commencer le X
je déjà je commencerai par dire que
c'est plus la mode he si part un gars il
non non non mais on est plus dans cette
air là attention on peut pas vivre les
mêmes choses à des décennies euh de en
je veux dire je suis arrivée là c'était
la mode alors je dis pas que je je veux
pas me m'excuser mais on sortait je sais
pas si tu as connu enfin nous on était
petit à notre époque parce qu'on a
presque le même âge l'époque mannequin
c'était vraiment la grande époque
mannequin Cindy cword tout tout Claudia
Schiffer toute cette époque c'était la
grande mode on les voyait partout on ne
voyait qu'elle et étrangement s passé au
X oui c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'était
on utilisait le terme star du X mais
c'était pas un terme galvodé c'était
vraiment c'était des stars et moi non
pas moi j'étais pas là a ouais et si tu
veux moi j'ai j'ai vu ovidi à la télé et
c'est ça qui a déclenché les choses chez
moi et c'était en même temps que ce
salon du c'est-à-dire qu'on m'a fait
cette proposition et puis ovidi passé
chez hardardisson et en fait elle avait
l'air intelligente elle l'était hein euh
c'était on l'appelait l'intello du X
parce qu'elle avit bac+
2 ça me faisait r parce que moi aussi
j'étais en bac + 2 j'étais ah en mode je
peux être prise pour une intell non mais
elle avait un discours féministe
intelligent de de femme qui n'est pas
contrainte j'avoue que ça a participé à
mon à ma décision et donc moi c'était
mon chemin mais aujourd'hui c'est le
chemin de qui ouais je veux dire c'est
qui fait du X quoi c'est c'est
complètement désué aujourd'hui on a
redonné le pouvoir aux femmes ça
s'appelle mime ça s'appelle only fan ça
s'appelle des sites qui donnent la
possibilité aux femmes si elles ont
envie de se dénuder de pouvoir le faire
directement auprès des gens que ça
intéresse et elles sont rémun ÉÉR
directement sans mec bizarre producteur
agent enfin pseudo agent tous ces gens
ben en fait qui vont bah c'est interdit
hein ça s'appelle du proxénétisme mais
ils l'ont
faitin de profiter de l'argent de de de
la nudité ou de la sexualité de de de de
quelqu'un c'est interdit aujourd'hui on
a résolu le problème les femmes qui ont
envie de se déshabiller d'être libre
avec leur corps et pourquoi pas de
vendre et leur et le
physique par photo par vidéo ou ou
directement et ben elles ont plus besoin
d'hommes ou de personnes elles le font
est-ce que ta question c'est qu'est-ce
que tu dirais à une femme qui a envie de
se lancer dans X parce que ça je pense
que cette question n'existe plus et ben
ça répond à la question du coup que
diraittu d'une fille qui a envie de se
montrer nu et d'en faire un métier ou en
tout cas une rente financière pour
pouvoir financer ses études et cetera
ben c'était pas ma question question
c'était pas ma question mais la réponse
elle m'intéresse tu es libre de ton
corps est-ce que c'est vraiment
nécessaire par ton envie ou par une
nécessité financière déjà pose-toi la
question sache également que ça restera
toujours est-ce que si tu te projettes
dans 10 dans 20 avec des enfants tu te
sens aujourd'hui la force ou la
décontraction de pouvoir l'expliquer à
tes enfants de pouvoir l'assumer à ton
patron auprès de ton d'un patron parce
que sache que 99 % des filles n'en font
pas leur métier je suis c'est vrai un
peu à part parce que j'ai jamais nié
parce que j'ai dit ok ça peutre
transformer évoluer comment et
d'ailleurs c'est toujours mon sujet
principal l'érotisme donc je suis
l'exemple pour dire c'est un choix qui
t'appartient sache que c'est ta vie
c'est c'est ta vie à vie non mais c'est
important et ce que je fais en tant que
maman c'est être totalement libre tous
les sujets sont évocables chaque
question a une réponse nous c'est la
liberté par contre j'essaie de lui
donner tous les moyens pour qu'elle
n'ait pas ce choix pour moi un peu
extrême si c'est son envie je ne suis je
suis personne pour lui dire au contraire
je veux dire je ne pourrais pas du tout
oui mais ce sera une question d'envie
pas une question de besoin pour répondre
à une condition financière c'est sa vie
et je la suivrai j'arrêterai tout pour
être à ses côtés sielle besoin de moi je
changerai de vie totalement et donc je
serai là qu'elle fasse le choix ou un
autre maintenant j'ai elle a une fibre
artistique donc depuis qu'elle a 4 ans
elle fait du piano elle chante elle
danse elle a des tonnes d'activités
artistiques euh et je pense qu'on peut
s'exprimer outre que par le corps
uniquement quand on est une femme et
même quand on est un homme donc je lui
donne les armes et elle en fera ce
qu'elle veut tu as utilisé plusieurs
fois le terme féministe c'est quoi ton
féminisme je serais curieux de
d'entendre ta réponse bien sûr mon
féminisme c'est déjà l'égalité c'est
l'égalité des droits des chances on n
est pas encore
sur sur le le le traitement équilibré
alors pas tous les hommes heureusement
j'ai je suis avec le mari le plus
féministe de la terre c'est-à-dire il
veut juste que je sois libre et en fait
c'est ça le féminisme vu de mon par mon
prisme et par le SU de mon mari
également c'est la liberté de pouvoir
avoir la vie rêvée alors on a beaucoup
avancé donc si tu me demandes quel est
mon féminisme c'est vraiment de
l'égalité la liberté de de de pouvoir se
réaliser à tous les niveaux euh au sein
de l'entreprise en tant qu'artiste je
dirais que c'est un petit peu plus
facile sauf quand on vient de mon milieu
parce que si on t'a vu nu si tu as été à
ce point humilié dans certaines dans
certains esprits tu ne pourras jamais
revenir à quelque chose de traditionnel
et en fait je crois que ça a été le
combat de ma vie mon combat féministe de
dire je ne suis pas une femme légère
parce qu'on m'a vu nu et en réalité je
veux montrer au nom des femmes qu'on
peut être dans tous les état libre de
l'être et à la fin d'être estimé par
quelques personnes simplement de son
mari de sa famille pas besoin de du
monde entier mais je pense que ma mère
est fière de moi mon père
[Musique]
et en fait ça me suffit pour me dire que
j'aiit les B Cho même si on m'a vu nu
j'en ai rien à ouis est-ce que tu
as un autre objectif un prochain
objectif un rêve est-ce qu'il y a un
autre domaine que tu aimerais explorer
alors là je sais et je pense qu'on
pourrait d'ailleurs terminé en parlant
de du spectacle qui a à venir de ton
retour dans la musique peut-être tu n'as
pas cloisonné c'estàd tu te laisse
l'opportunité de capter en fait ce qui
arrive et ben c'est très facile pour toi
de
ça c'est ça je me suis laissé ma propre
liberté quand d'autres forcément ne me
l' laissé pas forcément mais ce
spectacle me ravie parce que il réunit
toutes mes passions passion de la beauté
de l'esthétisme sur scène avec ses
costumes ses paillettes straces le monde
du spectacle la musique puisque je
reviens à la musique grâce au spectacle
vu que je chante la bande son de tout le
spectacle pendant que les artistes
incroyables alors c'est un SPECT
féministe je vais pas faire peur aux
hommes quand je dis féministe c'est pas
c'est pas tel que certains peuvent
l'entendre c'est juste que j'avais envie
de créer une ode aux femmes j'avais
envie de les mettre en avant en valeur
j'ai des femmes incroyables autour de
moi vis championne de pôle per acrobate
et feuilleuse Burles que j'avais envie
de les mettre en avant donc je chante je
performe aussi mais je vais pas trop en
dire j'ai fait 6 ans de cabaret pour
pouvoir créer le spectacle qui
finalement est et celui de mes rêves
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui voilà on
passe à la nouvelle Ève c'est génial qui
est quand même un un théâtre mythique
parisien qui dépend du Moulin Rouge qui
qui d'ailleurs est à deux pas on me
donne cette chance j'espère qu'on
réussira le Paris c'est 400 places c'est
tous les mardis au lieu d'une fois par
mois anciennement au César donc là c'est
tous les mardis à partir du 7 novembre
je frissonne je te cache pas mais je
sais que quand je sortirai de là je
serai meilleure parce que finalement ben
on a était dans sa chambre l'expérience
on la chope sur scène quoi et donc je
sais que après cette expérience j'aurais
un peu grandi encore un peu plus bah
écoute merci pour tout ce partage moi tu
m'impressionnes beaucoup ben en tout cas
je te remercie du fond du cœur j'ai
beaucoup d'estime pour toi je suis hyper
fière d'être là on a beaucoup de chance
que Clara ce soit autant livrée si vous
voulez la version un peu plus longue de
cette interview elle existe au format
podcast vous avez un lien dans la
description clara a commencé son
spectacle à la nouvelle èèvre je vous
mets aussi un lien dans la description
et je crois qu'il va également partir en
tournée et en parlant de tourée et mon
spectacle à moi aussi est également
tourné vous avez toutes les villes qui
s'affichent et c'est terminé à très
bientôt Ciao